the 2017 crop of superhero movies is
pretty impressive and it's safe to say
that more than one wildly exceeded
expectations if you're looking for the
best we're running down the 7 superhero
movies released by the major studios in
2017 ranked from worst to best minor
spoilers follow Justice League while
audiences have been somewhat forgiving
of the DC extended universe as growing
pains critics have been merciless
unfortunately Justice League proved no
exception on the bright side fans were
finally treated to a visceral thrill of
seeing Batman Superman Wonder Woman
Aquaman cyborg and the flash together on
the big screen but the film's uneven
plotting and forgettable villain are
hard to overlook those weaknesses were
mitigated to an extent by a couple of
rousing action sequences and the winning
presences of Jason Momoa as Aquaman and
Ezra Miller scene-stealing flash so it
may not have been the Justice League all
fans wanted but it was ultimately an
enjoyable if flawed vehicle for some of
the most beloved comic characters ever
to grace the page the Lego Batman movie
fans were delighted when the Lego Batman
movie a spin-off of 2014 surprisingly
excellent animated feature the lego
movie was announced the film continued
the emphasis on clever quirky layered
humor and rewarded fans of The Dark
Knight with a steady stream of
references to his past cinematic
incarnations as good as it was however
the Lego Batman movie is still largely
in essential it broke no new ground in
terms of superhero films or Batman
stories failing to hit the creative
highs of the years superior superhero
movies all reached in one way or another
it's squarely in the middle of the pack
but as an animated Lego outing it's
still a heck of a lot better than the
disappointing lego ninjago movie Logan
Hugh Jackman stunning 17-year run as
Wolverine and the x-men series may never
be surpassed and he could hardly have
gone out on a higher note than Logan the
film hit the right notes for the
character in a way that no previous
x-men movie truly had thanks to its grim
storyline and hard our rating which
finally allowed for an appropriately
Wolverine esque level of violence if
there was one consistent complaint about
the film it said it may have to
it's grim and melancholy tone a bit too
far the bleak and unforgiving world is
consistently rendered in stark dusty
tones and the fates of our major
characters aren't pretty Logan is a
great Wolverine movie at long last but
this year's best superhero movies were
able to tell stories every bit as
compelling and not quite as bleak
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 2014 s
guardians of the galaxy certainly
overperformed nobody expected a team of
virtually unknown characters featuring a
tree and a gun-toting raccoon to capture
the hearts of moviegoers but writer
director James Gunn brought passion and
vision not to mention a stellar cast to
the project Guardians overcame low
expectations to become one of Marvel's
most loved films meaning that its sequel
faced expectations that were anything
but low fortunately gun in this ragtag
team of space heroes largely delivered
with guardians of the galaxy vol 2 the
action sequences are even crazier this
time around but the family oriented
story also serves as a framework for
Gunn to explore some of the more
unlikely family dynamics of his
characters and to delve into some of the
more complex aspects of their
personalities vol 2 may not quite have
lived up to its predecessor but it
benefited from not trying too hard to
achieve that lofty goal plus any film
that features Kurt Russell as a quasi
immortal living planet in a human form
earns points for its sheer awesomeness
Wonder Woman the DC extended universe
has largely failed to live up to
expectations but there's one brilliant
exception director patty Jenkins Wonder
Woman starring gal gadot as a legendary
Amazonian blew away audiences
single-handedly resurrecting hope for
the DC EU as a whole Jenkins knocked all
kinds of holes in the well-worn theory
that audiences wouldn't respond to a
female centric superhero movie by
turning in a spectacularly shot and
choreographed well paced and flat-out
entertaining feature anchored by adults
alternately graceful and badass
performance
Wonder Woman suffers from only minor
imperfections plot wise it bears more
than a passing resemblance to Marvel's
Captain America the First Avenger and
some critics felt Chris
Pyne Steve Trevor could have been
de-emphasized in terms of the title
character's motivation but overall
Wonder Woman is a spectacular big-screen
solo debut for a character Hollywood is
famously struggled to adapt Jenkins def
directorial touch and refusal to
objectify her lead only serve to make
the character's subsequent appearance
and Justice League function as a
reminder of this far superior film
spider-man homecoming until 2015 Sony
Pictures held the sole film rights to
spider-man the first appearance of
Spidey in the MCU in 2016's Captain
America's Civil War proved what
audiences have long known spider-man
belongs in a larger universe with the
rest of Marvel's heroes underoos
hey everyone it doesn't hurt that Tom
Holland is terrific in the role of Peter
Parker or that Michael Keaton in a
casting masterstroke creates one of the
more compelling villains in the MCU as
Adrian Toomes also known as the vulture
but the true genius of homecoming is in
the decision to give us the bumbling
insecure fifteen-year-old Peter that
previous cinematic incarnations never
showed and delet interactions with cast
mates and other heroes inform and
develop the character as they've always
done in the comics this spider-man has
plenty of room to grow and his first
solo vehicle is an outstanding beginning
thor ragnarok
the best superhero film of 2017 had the
lowest expectations of them all thor
ragnarok seemed like almost an
afterthought except two fans who'd been
paying attention the signing of indie
director Tycho ytt piqued the interest
of those familiar with his unique comic
voice when you're a vampire you become
very sexy
and the news that the plot would
incorporate elements of the Planet Hulk
storyline from the comics as well as
intriguing cast additions including Cate
Blanchett and Jeff Goldblum clued them
in that they might be in for something
special
Thor Ragnarok destroyed critical and box
office expectations by finding the
innate silliness of the MC use god of
thunder schooled the revenge's revenge
as you know I mean we don't have to have
a name we could have no name the movie's
non-stop humor is liberally balanced
with plenty of stunning action a
brilliant soundtrack and a truly
threatening villain in Blanchett's hella
the welcome returns of Tom Hiddleston's
Loki and Mark Ruffalo's Bruce Banner
slash Hulk not to mention some strongly
drawn new characters and one well-placed
Doctor Strange cameo connect the film to
the larger MCU but Thor Ragnarok is its
own singularly insane flick and one of
Marvel's best here's hoping we get a wot
TT directed Thor for as soon as possible
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]